it's gun week now the founding fathers
understood that only an armed people
could truly be a free people so this
week I invite you to join me the mud
club's resident gun Aficionado Mr gunzen
here
as we tackle the subject of firearms
from every angle possible today's
episode we take on all of the basics
that you need to know
about rifles and shotguns this is long
guns 101.
day two of gun week with Mr gear you
know him as guns and gear but doctor
gear depending uh honorary yes honorary
doctor today we'll be discussing why the
four firearms safety rules or the
universal safety rules of firearms
handling are wrong I had a high school
teacher who I found out he had an
honorary doctorate in philosophy
um so I just call him I call him Bob uh
we're doing long guns today so we did
pistols we're going to do common myths
associated with firearms and we'll also
do a ballistics gel video some pretty
cool cameras but long guns encompassing
rifles and shotguns if you're not a gun
person again we're trying to provide you
with an entry point uh let's explain to
people first I guess what you would be
taking into account why you might need a
long gun right and what might be
appropriate so long guns increase
lethality generally speaking the
cartridges they fire are more powerful
they have longer barrels that has more
energy traditionally you think of like
hunting you're going to be using a rifle
in most cases for that additionally
they're just easier to shoot well the
reason for that is you have more points
of contact on the on firearm so just as
an example as opposed to if we had
there's no good way by the way we're in
a very limited space okay we know it's
right unloaded so Corey doesn't like me
um but so your point of contact is here
you also have a contact point on your
cheek your hand here and then out here
so it's much easier to control and get
accurate hits than it is with a pistol
that's just out here in space
additionally depending on the type of
firearm you get in AR-15 for example
Your Capacity can go up as well right
and so really with long guns a little
bit different from handguns we're
talking about you know a bedside firearm
and you recommended you sort of people
getting the first gun you recommend a
handgun because it could be more
multi-purpose correct with a long gun
you're probably looking at hunting home
defense or really target shooting right
maybe competitive shooting yeah maybe
yeah maybe competitive shooting so we
have a couple of different uh Firearms
here we have uh basic pump shotgun we
have a Benelli M4 semi-automatic shotgun
and of course America's favorite rifle
the AR-15 we have a couple of variations
here actually they come from Watchtower
it's the last American Firearms
manufacturer every single component is
American they're doing it here in the
United States and it's pretty cool
company that just formed so thanks to
them for uh for providing these just to
be clear we have this because it's
patriotically the same I would never
it's a work of art but I mean I would
have to be like a pimp who loves his
country and this is their uh base model
AR-15 you know kind of an easier point
to entry uh these have been zeroed in so
let's go first before we get to the air
50 we'll probably have a lot on that uh
explain to people the difference you
know shotgun rifle I know that everyone
watching with a gun enthusiast you know
the difference a lot of people don't
I'll get asked that like we're doing the
same thing right yeah so shotguns
generally speaking are going to fire 12
gauge or 20 gauge is the most common and
what that means is it's just a larger
projectile and most shotgun rounds not
all uh have multiple projectiles in them
whether they be bird shot or shot
uh birdshot generally speaking is
designed for exactly what it sounds like
birds Buckshot is designed for what it
sounds like animals Buckshot typically
is going to have anywhere from 8 to 12
pellets in it which is individual uh
pieces of metal uh whereas birdshot can
have tons it feels like ah spread if you
just aim a shotgun in the Gen direction
right it's going to eviscerate it and
typically you have two different types
of shotguns which this one here is a
pump axle shotgun this is a Remington
870 probably the most manufactured
shotgun in the world uh very very common
you have to manually work the action
with each shot so basically you're going
to press the trigger and then at that
point you'll be able to cycle the next
round into the action and just keeps
going until it's out of rounds whereas
we have the binoy M4
arguably the best semi-automatic shotgun
in the planet and this one is
semi-automatic meaning every time you
pull the trigger it will make it will
cycle by itself rather and self-load
until it's out of bounds and same thing
with the AR-15s just to be clear
semi-automatic again I know it's
remedial for some people that means you
pull the trigger once and it fires one
round
[Music]
did that hit they use the term automatic
semi-automat they try to say
semi-automatic so they think it's a
machine gun we'll do another installment
on that AR-15 is a semi-automatic uh
rifle for more on these go to
watchtowerfirearms.com veteran owned and
the last true American firearm
manufacturer Let's uh go we'll shoot all
of these but um I guess we might as well
it's pretty easy to pick which one you
want you know a rifle or a shotgun uh
why you might any of these would be
suitable for home defense yep for sure
now for shotguns uh they're gen if
you're using defensive loads they're
going to have more recoil uh for sure
especially than an AR-15 air 15 is very
light recoiling gun whereas a shotgun if
you're using slugs or Buckshot it's
definitely going to have some punch to
it so if you're somebody who's recoil
averse just keep that in mind as well
right and look I will say I don't want
to Veer you one way but an AR-15 does
make a lot of sense for people looking
for a rifle for home defense it is
versatile it can be used for hunting in
the proper scenarios very easy to
control very light recoiling very
reliable model of Fire and there's a
reason that it's incredibly popular it's
something that's pretty easy for people
to use I mean right it would be tough
for someone to go wrong with a good
quality AR-15 yes assuming it's a good
quality one that's your point yes
and we do that with Watchtower they are
and we do know that there are a lot of
but they're yeah there's some out there
that are awful I mean that bullet would
hit them sideways yes that's a real
thing now like you saying though I take
a lot of new Shooters out just doing
what I do and a lot of them knowing
nothing about guns will gravitate to the
AR-15s just because they're very
pleasant to shoot and they don't even
understand that it has more stopping
power than pistols um they're just
looking at it because it's more pleasant
to shoot easier to shoot well so let's
um really quickly what we'll do is we
have the magic of a Time Warp we'll
clear the table and then focus on kind
of a basic AR model and we'll do a
safety check explain the basics and
announce and then we'll go to the range
sounds good
[Music]
foreign okay so basic uh safety checking
like we do the handguns uh the scariest
rifle in existence as we well know the
AR-15 uh this is watchtower's kind of
more basic model obviously high quality
but without uh as many bells and
whistles as this being skeletonized so
uh Mr gunzing here show people if they
approach an AR-15 you know sure so if
you actually find one of these in the
street good for you
um but it's going to be most likely in
this configuration here with our bolt
carrier group which is this part here
forward so basically the way to check
and see if it's loaded is we're going to
pull on our charging handle and then on
the left side of the rifle we have this
piece here which is our bolt block and
bolt release and so doing it on camera
is a little weird but you're going to
push in and lock that back
at that point you can look in the
chamber verify that it is unloaded and
proceed accordingly the other controls
that you need to know about here are
going to be your safety on this gun it's
ambidextrous meaning it's on both sides
of the gun however many of them will be
left side only that is the fire position
that is the safe position unfortunately
this one doesn't have a third position
but if we had our rights we would have a
third position that would go forward and
you'd be able to fire at first like hey
let's start our sent us free guns
there's a sponsor I realized he was it
was a rights thing yes so so
unfortunately this one doesn't have that
uh here is our trigger of course in
order to fire it it will have to be in
the fire position this is actually a
match trigger so it's kind of a fancy
one
and then over on this side of the rifle
we have our magazine release which is
this button right here and so if we had
our magazine in there
you could push that
and it will come out those are your
basic controls on AR-15 yeah it's uh
it's pretty simple we'll take it apart
after we go to the range and kind of
show people how to clean it a little
more involved in some of the handguns uh
but not nearly as intimidating as you
would think so this is one where
definitely will bring in Gerald and I
haven't fired actually an AR uh in a
while because I've been firing a nine
millimeter Carbine the last couple of
years and I gifted it I did a legal
transfer to my friend who had moved here
so we could have a long gun and he
couldn't have a handgun it was my only
AR so I haven't used one probably in a
couple of years so this this will be
remedial let's go to the range and you
show us how to hit the broad side of a
barn I'll do my best
foreign
with long guns uh one of us has a
significantly more experience than the
rest so we'll be doing uh seated
shooting which you just said is almost
impossible to screw up it's pretty hard
I'll do my best so we'll see when we
were zeroing in the sides I kept hitting
the target 100 yards I thought hey
that's not then he was like well
basically a nutless monkey can do that
we'll see it's at the bar so low I still
have to shoot and then we'll do some
standing uh but the AR is something that
a lot of people probably want to focus
on because it's very popular it's very
likely that they'll be choosing it one
thing that people here notice it's a lot
louder than it is uh recoiling yeah and
so do you think that's maybe kind of why
people get the wrong uh impression of it
uh well that's certainly part of it it
depends how your rifle's set up these
ones are set up with muzzle brakes which
help with mitigating recoil and getting
fast follow-up shots some people like
that but they're definitely louder if
you had a flashlight on there it would
cut that down oh okay uh to be clear he
doesn't like muscle brakes
it's a matter of reference he was like I
don't like muzzle breaks because of how
loud it is it's like it doesn't make it
easier it's not worth it
um so show us uh kind of the the basic
need to knows about uh firing a rice or
some tips like just like you do with the
handcuffs yep sure so uh with an AR-15
uh it's not as applicable seated but
what you want to do is set your length
up pull most AR-15s are going to have an
adjustable buttstock how it actually
articulates is going to vary on the
brand but this one's a mission first
tactical and you just push this little
button and you can set it up to whatever
length you want I'm six feet tall so for
me when I'm seated or prone I tend to
like it about this length but some folks
are a little bit smaller but want to put
it down just just looks comfortable
um the military typically even still
teaches that you want your nose to be
close to the charging handle that's just
for consistency so that's for having a
consistent sight picture when you look
down range if you notice with sights
like this one has backup iron sights if
you had your iron sights up and you move
your head around
it'll look like where your shooting
moves so they want your point where you
actually Mount the rifle on your face to
be consistent that's why they teach it
I'm not sure that's necessary just
throwing that out there because I know
someone's saying it in the comments
so so where you actually want to place
your hand obviously this one we have a
light which is going to drive that to
some extent but
exceeded honestly you just want it
wherever it's the most comfortable and
you can get the most stable some of you
are shorter might have to come back here
some of you are real tall may have to go
out here to this grip that we have one
thing you will see it's a left over from
like the 80s military training is a lot
of folks will grip right here I don't
recommend doing that number one you
don't get any stability and additionally
it can cause malfunctions if you
actually had one of these if you had one
of those which this gun doesn't
um but yeah that's pretty much it and
the key here is unlike with handguns
where you have to stabilize the gun
while you're shooting it essentially if
you're out of a seated position like
this you just want to mount the gun to
the table I.E press it in so that way
you get the added stability that you get
so with that all right I'm loading it is
pretty simple we have this lock back but
if it wasn't again we're just going to
push this button right here pull our
charging handle back
at this point take our magazine bullets
down range
set it in at this point we can either
charge the charging handle just like the
pistols we talked about or we can just
hit this button
and now the rifle is loaded
um and just I'll take a few shots to
show that but so at this point your ears
gonna want your ears on and uh safety
we're just going to rotate it down to
fire like we talked about I guess this
one is ambidextrous are those your
daughters
they don't fit
yeah I'm the one who beats you think I
think look at this there's an intern
getting fired okay all right so what I
mean by that uh in terms of
getting on the table and physically get
on the table 100 yards yeah okay the
same would be true if you were firing
from the prone I.E playing on the ground
position okay
um with older magazines that in theory
could cause malfunction but if you have
modern AR-15 magazines it will not and
the reason for that is just changing the
angle of feet modern magazines account
for that so it's not an issue so get in
there and use it as a point of contact
all right so again to fire we're just
going to push the safety down no he's
64.
and at this point um you want the rifle
to be somewhere in your shoulder pocket
uh some instructors will teach more
Center Line some will teach a little bit
in the meat of your shoulder
with an AR-15 I generally don't think it
really matters uh there's so little
recoil so 100 yards
[Music]
that's really it that is the loading
operation Etc of an error 15.
okay well since uh Mr Mr gear made it
look so easy at a hundred yards uh airs
heirs
our lovely uh senior producer Nancy just
came in but she doesn't have ears and I
don't want her to be deaf
she's got ears then she'll be saying
that was great can we do another take
all right let's see uh Mr guns and gear
is gonna make us all look like hacks
which we are
well I think we'll just assume that the
rest of the magazine was going to go
that way ah come on uh you know I just
you know I just don't wanna I don't
wanna uh I don't want to wear it out
before you guys get to it that's yeah
that's fair I appreciate that yeah well
it's very patriotic I mean uh it was
most of the work was done by Earth again
we're sitting so it's not very hard I
think it'll be very different from what
we stand but Jill have you you have
fired an AR-15 I believe Gerald has yeah
it's been it's been I think quite a
while I don't even remember okay but I
think it was at a range up north one
time oh that's right we did really
quickly out again these come from uh
Watchtower this is a kind of a
specialized obviously it looks really
cool American flag it's a very patriotic
uh but uh this is meant for people who
kind of really like tricking out their
their ARs and um sometimes you know you
run into like compatibility issues where
it's a little a little more finicky with
like magazines this is their base model
here that they sent to us uh from
watchtower in American Firearms
manufacture everything here in the USA
and um they really do have a great
mission statement and a reason for
founding the company veteran owned and
not just by the way veteran owned but
people who are aggressively Pro Second
Amendment and you have to worry about
them that's not always that's for sure
uh no I don't it's just for men
all right this one let's see because uh
uh by the way I should say that Mr
gunzinger spent some time uh getting the
Red Dot on this adjusted so if I miss
it's because he's it's because he's he's
no Jeweler
now you should know
when it comes to shooting I suck so
there's a reason that a lot of people
would pick an air it's very very easy to
shoot
[Music]
um and we'll have Gerald I'm sure we'll
have pointers but like you said it does
seem as far as from a defensive
perspective if you're sitting
it's pretty tough to screw up it is
um especially if you have an optic on
there yeah um it definitely makes it
easy it's just put the dot on it press
trigger well and the trigger on that
thing is again really easy all right
Gerald we'll do musical chairs you have
your eye protection I've got it but you
got it okay you got your normal that's
built in I keep them
tall so a little bit you might want to
extend that butt stock all the way out I
don't think it's quite all the way
so what we're gonna do is pull up yep oh
no it is all the way all right well
that's good that's where you want to be
uh basically you're going to want to
orient the gun towards the target
say aim at the Target I did but I tried
to say it in a nice way yeah I tried to
say it in a way that didn't make it feel
so
um and then basically get the butt stock
in your shoulder somewhere in this
region
uh lean into it so that way it
stabilizes it okay
yep you say aim that way yeah okay yeah
that Orient was my word hey uh just one
sec can I take out just a second to say
this is nice it was nice it was nice
very nice it's good good to be with you
all have enjoyed your cup yes sir yes
that away
I feel like I have to like really lean
down into this thing yeah it's because
you're tall well yeah because
all right shut up
you know what helps safety yeah it's
safety first I was seeing if he knew and
he didn't say anything about it so but
we found out at work there's a testament
it's part of the review process
[Music]
yeah
I got it
I got four all right you only did three
on the trigger it's not it's not and the
guns pointed that way so yeah but you
know what that's where that's World
Susie range hangs out so uh we're safe
let's um let's obviously if he can do it
four times in a row we need to do
something standing it seems like for
this oh come on man it doesn't mean
anything
yeah so uh let's Time Warp and let's go
learn some real technicians
thank you
[Music]
Zoom jump okay so now we're standing
which is did you have that show in the
states Zoom
no no no okay it was a Canadian thing
all right all right so it's not going
over never mind going over firing error
15 standing just like you talked about
with the stock
um you want to adjust it to you this is
more applicable uh standing than it is
uh from a bench so kind of a rule of
thumb
if you will is you want it to be about
the length
when you grip it to where your elbow
joint is and then adjust from there so
that's like the starting point then move
it in or out depending on what you like
and how it feels to you
um so again uh like we talked about you
want your stock to be somewhere in this
area the proponents of keeping it more
Center Line say that it's going to help
with recoil mitigation which
might be true
um but some folks who want it it's kind
of hard to tell because there's not much
recoil exactly and so uh when it's a
little bit more on the outside people
who have more of a bladed stance will
prefer that
um whichever one you have are there
certain set points like for people who
are you know they're like okay your
cheek should be here
um where if it just kind of gives them
something that's almost you know like
like clockwork that they can do every
time right yeah so
when you have your rifle set up for home
defense or whatever the case may be like
ready to go you'll have the stock
already in that position when you pick
it up it'll just naturally go there so
one thing that and you want your cheek
you're saying is it's right along there
that's what I was going to go oh sorry
one thing that new shoes I hear maybe
part of it so I don't even know if I'm
asking questions that you've already
answered it's all good we've been very
patient with us please so one thing that
a lot of new air Shooters will do is
they'll put it like this and then you'll
see them craning their neck down what
you want is it's just like martial arts
so if you're standing shooting you want
to be able to move and beat athletic
essentially because that might be
required of you so what you really want
with an AR most of your stocks are a
little bit different like for example
this one
that reason that curve is there is
actually for what I'm about to say so
the reason that curve is there is so it
fits better when it's high up okay so
when you want to bring your rifle up you
want to minimize how much you have to
move your head you're going to have to
move it some somewhat with most Optics
but you want to minimize it have it be
as natural of a position as possible
like that there are different Optics
that are different heights so if you're
uncomfortable with the way it is you can
change that and then with your
non-dominant hand there's different
schools of thoughts on this similar to
like we talk about pistols in terms of
being all the way out or being a little
bit bent I personally like to be
slightly bent so my arm's going to be
somewhat like that so it's more
important than when you're sitting 100
right 100 because what you're doing is
you're using that hand to pull the rifle
into your shoulder okay this hand is
doing virtually nothing in terms of
controlling recoil all you're doing with
this hand is manipulating switches
that's one of the reasons that sometimes
learning on lever actions are valuable
because that when you learn to do it
this they taught me this hand should
basically there should be no weight this
is supporting it so that's how you can
operate it quickly correct and that kind
of drilled it in my head where sometimes
although semi-automatic you don't really
think of it you're just thinking just
grab it and support it so yep yep for
sure and uh again you want to pull it
back into your shoulder to mitigate that
recoil and uh other than that I mean
that's pretty much it you'll see some
competition Shooters shoot like this but
the reason they shoot like that and
they're not pulling it back so hard is
because they don't care about follow-up
shots whereas in the real world you want
to put as many shots on target as
possible until whatever caused you to
start shooting stops right does that
make sense right so it makes sense yeah
all right so essentially it's going to
look something like this
[Music]
thank you
that's it that's
it what's up do you hit all three I
don't know I have to see the replay yeah
he did he did let's just assume he did
all right let me try I'll try it with
this one just because I mean sounds good
it's gun week so
why not use a patriotic fire so uh does
that seem that's too much too long of a
length to pull so this is a difference
Some people prefer a more bladed stance
like this Some people prefer to be more
squared up
um that comes from like the global war
on terrorism days when we as soldiers
started training with body armor so
folks who were wearing body armor
started shooting more squared up to get
the plates exposed yeah um it's kind of
a preference thing I really don't think
one is right or wrong does that seem
about yep something about right yep
you're probably going to want to be a
little bit higher
okay and your hand out a little that
feels like it's not bracing against my
shoulder at that point no it's not and
so one thing if you lower that real
quick scene
um
is that
you want to pick it up okay all right
sorry all right like you're gonna shoot
it yep okay yeah no I've never held this
out further right like this so this is
kind of new to me I usually have always
held it here yep and that's okay okay
there's nothing wrong with that
um but you really want to have that
higher up so that way you're not
creating your neck because that's what
you're starting to do right so yep and
you want to just
the way to think of it is you want to
kind of like fall into the rifle so
instead of being like this if you just
take a natural again like you're talking
about okay so oh so I almost want to
feel it more in the crease of where my
chest meets my shoulder correct okay
what you just did that motion is almost
think like a prawn a little bit correct
okay yes but it's actually very similar
to you know they would talk about in
boxing where uh you know blah guys they
square up you actually kind of want to
roll your shoulders in to protect your
chin right okay that actually helps a
lot because I was thinking I wanted it
up against yep so you're going to come
up and basically just kind of naturally
go into it okay there you go yep much
better all right I don't see it now as
much better I just stepped on a
is it a 50 caliber and shell or just a
tip too if you're starting out shooting
and you don't already have bad habits
keep your elbow in that's just a good
thing it's less to get shot less areas
in my elbow out in but was my elbow out
no it wasn't no it was good so I did
good yes
I thought I just assumed it was
criticism I mean I'm used to it just
making a point all right so that seems
about right okay
[Music]
thank you
did that hit yeah
[Music]
foreign
so that wasn't that wasn't bad I mean
obviously I wouldn't be able to do fast
follow-up shots but I don't have nearly
the experience but that does that makes
a huge difference of course now I do
wonder if I got used to this that that
might make more sense yeah um it's just
very foreign to me going out which I
know right a lot of the a lot of people
now this is kind of the trend right to
go out way way further for sure
um you definitely are if you do it
correctly you're more stable with your
hand out further because all of your
movements are a little bit uh more
precise on the end it's just physics
um but you will fatigue quickly which is
why you'll see it a lot in the
competition world where they're running
a stage for 20 seconds you're not going
to see a Marine in a firefight
but in the real world doing that right I
was going to say okay all right Gerald
you want to have a go yeah I'll hit with
this one here want to do with that one
okay
and again it's what we are fortunate to
be able to shoot pretty
highly highly engineered rifles that do
a lot of work now see for him that's not
even far no because he has a wingspan of
an albatross the wandering Albatross has
the longest wingspan of any bird alive
today
I gotta see where the dot did we turn
the dot off on this nope Time
[Music]
wait can you not see the dot because
you're colorblind I'm not even joking I
could see it oh there it is I don't know
how that worked I did it again you let
me do it too Mike
it's okay
that's enough that's enough yeah he shot
enough
figure out the trigger box like I told
you in the trigger side so you know he
picked something up and he's like I
don't know but he's like Baby Huey am I
doing right
I don't know is that okay it runs a 40.
like well it's blunder five good
yeah
it's frustrating he's frustratingly
gifted sorry
it's not my fault no that was good any
tips that we're doing wrong that we need
to fix um Gerald was a little bit high
on it but yeah that's just because
you're new to it so when you say hi on
it tell me meaning standing very
vertical okay so I didn't fit in like
you were talking a little bit more okay
just more stable because think about
like put your hands like this so what
you're trying to do right is you're
trying to stop that Force right because
it's moving me back but if I lean into
it correct okay there we go yeah that's
what I'm trying to do okay cool awesome
that was better than I heard some some
basic tips uh I guess we do still have
we have some other long guns here yeah I
mean I think you guys probably know
we've fired a few pump shotgun but
probably would be pretty cool if you'll
see the Spinelli at work it's a
semi-automatic shotgun we have some of
these little uh these little terrorists
set up here uh so let's let's do that
MTV
Zoom jump I just forgot you guys don't
have zoom uh so shotguns really quickly
pretty self-explanatory not all two
different from rifles except you've been
using them at closer range right yeah uh
for sure and same thing in terms of
increased points contact stability that
you get versus the pistol right same
advantages we'll go through some of the
myths uh when we do that the idea that
you just aim in the general direction no
there is a spread but it's not
necessarily what you've been told this
is a classic Remington pump action
shotgun 870. and this is a Benelli
semi-automatic shotgun this is one thing
if you understand kinetic energy the
kick in this is substantially more than
this because a part of that energy right
is being used to cycle the next round
whereas this is just basically in a
closed chamber going off in your
shoulder
um yeah that's exactly what it is it's
the least Pleasant with Buckshot it's no
for sure it's no joke you want to take a
shot of that first yeah and so both of
these are loaded with full power buck so
yeah and then we'll uh use the Benelli
and show Gerald
[Music]
oh
you really had to lean into that a
little bit right you want to yeah yeah
if you don't you'll find out why
we have a medic on site
you guys ready yep
around his ass
[Music]
boom that really is not a lot of kick no
it's not a shotgun
that's why I recommend it let's uh you
know what
since this is Gerald's first time let's
really quickly let's put up all those
targets and just have Gerald blow them
all away sounds good oh geez
hold right here the safety right here so
it's a safety push across so it's good
now no okay got it all right sorry
yeah yeah we're gonna die
yeah right there
[Music]
honestly out of everything today that
was surprisingly inaccurate first I'm
kind of amazed you missed it well I
didn't want to lean right I was I was
afraid let's put that away I want
another shot all right I want another
shot okay I could do better but we
weren't even supposed to be filming this
one just so we got rid of the target
before it but
[Music]
is this what you're supposed to go
outside and shoot it in the air
according to Joe Budden double barrel
okay got it yeah okay put that double
barrel shotgun and fire two blasts
outside the house well we were going to
have Gerald do this but since he missed
with a bomb shot I was worried about my
shoulder we'll talk about your fast for
a shotgun uh four targets this is why
you hear people talk about this thing so
much
[Music]
nice it's kind of silly it is it is it's
kind of like cheat codes but you have to
keep in mind too that versus the pump
shotgun huge price difference right so
this is barrier to entry to getting into
it yeah no it's not great if you're one
of the pores
that's nice yeah it's nice I gotta get
one of these oh the Barrel's hot don't
touch the barrel
that figure hurts that cruise and make
bacon on that Barrel
what it's okay cook a steak on that
Barrel wow that was nice
the vanilla is nice all right if you can
afford one of these I highly recommend
it now the funnest part cleaning
no see that's the magic of cameras and
by the way if you feel that this has uh
enlightened you or served you in any way
uh hit the like button subscribe and of
course go check out Mr guns into your
channel thank you to Watchtower for uh
providing these Firearms oh you go and
watch the one we're most excited about
is dispelling a lot of those gun myths
things like uh things like the 22
bouncing around on the body cavity
things uh like uh the Firearms were only
meant for muskets or the second
amendment that the militia uh that you
don't need that kind of capacity all
those will be covered in other videos
click one of those links okay this is
the least fun part for most people and
they're intimidating with ar because
they're more moving parts right than a
hand sure they are it's bigger too it's
scary it doesn't have to be that hard to
clean it no there's some intricacies to
it okay um first thing we're going to
want to do of course is verify that it's
clear this one already is but if not you
just pull the charging handle back to
verify it's clear at this point we're
going to pull it back and release or hit
our bolt release to send it home we're
gonna push out the pins so there's two
pins on an AR-15 one here at the rear
one up front
on a new gun like this it can be tight
well so Watchtower said hey these things
are very very tight so you might need a
normal yeah
that's one thing also too because people
may need to know a lot of times
um sometimes guns that are meant for
like precision shooting right you have
tighter tolerances right because they
want to be Precision Instruments as
opposed to that's one of the myths we'll
sort of get to mil specs sometimes they
want looser tolerance that function
correct right with dirt with crap in it
but they may not be as uh precise that's
true yeah so at this point you can
either swing your lower down as tight
they're not kidding this is the first
day he literally said you're going to
have to do something to get it out I
didn't tell him beforehand because I
just wanted to mess with him but
we want you to realize that Mr guns in
here is a fraud
at AR-15 that is tight we're gonna hold
this over his head for a little while
pink panties come on Mike no it's uh
this is a brand new firearm
30 minutes later don't worry we're
running a real Gun Pro he's yeah
it's Stanley Tucci oh yeah that doesn't
make sense in all seriousness if you
actually have a tight lower like that
sometimes if you free up the front pin
here uh it will loosen the rear one yeah
which is exactly what I just did so uh
for normal maintenance that's probably
all you need to do for your lower
receiver
and then at this point you're going to
pull your charging handle this one's
ambidextrous and we're going to pull our
bolt carrier group out which is this
piece right here and then pull our
charging handle out and at this point
for normal maintenance all you need to
do is take apart the bolt and that is it
so okay so let me kind of here I'll move
this so it's not in the way this very
cool
but gaudy I feel like it's a gun Kid
Rock would have yes for a music video
yes exactly but it is it is cool but
very cool I mean it camouflages I guess
if you're if you are like at a trump
rally if you would like Service uh so
this component this component right
these are the main components lower
receiver upper receiver this is the bolt
uh charging handle yep for the bolt
carrier bolt carrier group okay whole
carrier group so I just pulled this
little pin out I'm not sure if the
camera caught it but this is our firing
pin retainer pin then you're just going
to tip it up like that firing pin comes
out
gonna move our bolt to the rear until
it's at the back of this cam track right
here
and at this point you can rotate it 90
degrees like that
cam pin will come out
and our bolt is assembled disabled
excuse me for normal maintenance this is
as far as you're going to take it down
you can obviously take these down much
further but day-to-day maintenance don't
need to okay so what we'll do is
probably the same thing with the
handguns I'm assuming spray it all down
brush the carbon for sure if you have an
old lady's tank top and we're also going
to um for snakes of course naked you
could use patches as well if you want to
spray some CLP in the bore before you
can before you do so rather okay that
way it goes down while the bore snake
goes down feel free to do so and can I
ask you something because if you go
online there and you know this there'll
be people saying run ARS dry so we're
saying run them wet some people saying
just a tiny amount there are different
camps what is sort of correct based on
the actual data because there's a lot of
data there's a ton of data DOD has done
a lot of testing on it it's all public
you can look it up and virtually all
conditions it's going to run better if
you have it on the Wet Side okay okay so
a lot of people think it'll attract dirt
with the oil and it'll stay there which
is true but the oil suspends it and
still works fine okay
so we do that and then I would assume
spray all these components correct in
the lower receiver and the upper
receiver just right on in there get rid
of the excess yep so what we're going to
wipe it down and basically you're just
going to spray it in your trigger group
there and wipe it all down
additionally in the AR-15 it has what's
called a Star Chamber which is this
portion right here and we're going to
want to make sure that we get into there
with some sort of cloth that's because
you get a lot of build up specifically
there yes the way the AR-15 works that
spot gets very very dirty and it's also
right where your rounds are going into
the chamber so you kind of want that to
be clean and you said that with an AR-15
we didn't necessarily need this with the
handgun but you do recommend maybe a
couple drops of oil uh more kind of a
thinner coating oil yes that's for sure
so some sort of petroleum-based
lubricant now on the bolt here same
thing I just sprayed it with that CLP
and make sure you want to get a bolt
face as well the reason is that right
there is where the cartridge is going to
lock onto the rim okay and you want that
to get a good purchase so that way you
can pull it out reliably
all right and then here on a bulk
Carrier Group same thing we're getting a
spray in there because that is where
this bolt is moving back and forth
inside there okay sort of like a piston
engine if you guys are familiar with
that spray down the outside of it and
how often would you need to clean a
lubricate an AR-15 so yeah in my mind
literally not very often is the answer
to that
realistically if you have a good AR-15
easily a thousand rounds should be able
to run reliably provided it's lubricated
if you had a suppressor speeds that up
you have to clean it a little bit more
but what I would recommend is if you're
using it as a defensive gun or a hunting
on it something that you want to depend
on I would clean it after each use okay
if you're going to actually depend on it
like a basic cleaner correct okay that's
what I do so I'm just going through now
wiping everything up
and then can you do us a favor and put
it back together so people see the order
we can get those written different
close-ups because I know it's something
these little it can be intimidating
because there's some little tiny pieces
but once you know it really does become
second nature yep for sure all right so
with that and are you able to do this
wrong like that when I was we were
talking about the handguns when I was
practicing on the PPS after we finished
I just wanted to do it I had this stupid
thought in my head I was like What if I
do it wrong right it's not possible are
you able to do this wrong no no no you
do it well um the answer is yes the
general human being out there doing this
sure myself as well okay uh so on most
of your AR-15s if they're mil-spec I.E
compatible with all the other AR-15
parts no you can't okay there are some
kind of go one way to make everything
fit correctly there are some that have
bolts that can be put in backwards but
that's not normal okay
um like 99.9 no okay um so that's
helpful to know because it makes it to
where it's like okay I can't quite screw
this up and then go out to the range and
blammo that's also why these are so
popular because there's so many
aftermarket parts and accessories
because it's relatively standardized
look at that you can make an AR-15 into
almost any kind of a firearm you want
depending on you know your chosen kind
of motive of Opera operation I guess
yeah yeah for sure all right
I'm gonna use the gun cleaning Lube on
my phone yeah that's a good idea right
in your eyes get a little lead in there
yeah all right so uh what we're gonna do
is take our bolt and you want your bolt
to be excuse me the extractor facing to
the right because that's how it goes
here on our upper receiver okay and
again you can't with a mil-spec one you
cannot do that backwards okay now this
is this is our cam pen it can go in
either way okay
um and basically Ah that's the problem
right we need to clean it again son of a
gun these guns actually have it I'll
just use my forehead grease right that's
basically that should work this boat
carrier group actually has a very
special treating on it that makes it
super slippery
um so that's not normal but regardless
um but that would be a good thing for
operations low friction yeah yep 100
there's a lot of stuff that he told me
that I did forget to tell you Mike why
apologize last minute he brought this in
yeah and I said Jill can you handle this
yeah you said yes what Jim meant to say
was no I don't own an AR-15 but yes I
will take care of this please tell me
all of the details yeah so I said Gerald
what do you tell you he said ah it works
good works good looks nice right hey
it's going to be green yeah so once you
put your campaign in you have to push it
forward and rotate it 90 degrees if you
don't rotate it you won't be able to get
your firing pin in so your firing pin
pin goes down and just drops right in
there like that oh wow that's a good and
then you're gonna take your retaining
pen and push it across
like so now your bolt carrier group is
good to go can I just tell you one thing
because I know you're probably being
very polite but confused he's colorblind
he thinks this is green what is it yeah
it's a tan this isn't really great I
wouldn't that's not his tan for yeah
it's 10. all right I was lied to you're
okay so provided you cleaned everything
out of there
um are we gonna go over lubrication
before we put it together uh if you yeah
if there's specific Parts again unlike
what the handgun if you go back we
showed you a basic way to do it with a
CLP you don't really need to do an extra
step if you're just looking to keep it
functioning and reliable with an AR it
is recommended that you do use something
like is this a we have hops number nine
yeah so lubricating oil uh anything
petroleum-based should be good generally
speaking but we're gonna put it on our
bolt here okay probably should have done
it before I do it but if you didn't do
it before you did it like I just did you
can actually put it right down on the
cam track and it'll do the exact same
thing just a drop yep tiny amount okay
so I mean you can put it you can put a
little bit more and then also on the
rails here you can see on the bolt
carrier group there's rails so that's
what's actually making contact in the
upper receiver as you and we don't need
to worry about this being too wet no a
little bit because you know you will get
people like that's too wet
yes yeah you can see the dod data they
spent millions of dollars to get it so
just check it out
that's what they want you to do I mean
Rumble because that's where they go and
so on our charging handle there's a
little nub right here and these two Nubs
on the side you want those to be
lubricated
we're gonna put it in there's a little
Groove in your upper receiver
that these two pieces go in so you're
going to put it in go down like that and
then put your bolt carrier group in you
want your bolt forward all the way
forward because if it's not it won't go
in and we're going to align this gasket
which is this portion right here with
the groove and our charging handle
that's it sent it home and at this point
you're just going to attach your little
receiver
hopefully the pins are by pushing a
little more friendly going back in might
be easier to do a timeline oh there we
go
that is tight all right oh there we go
there you go look got this reassembled
ready to go nice awesome there you go
look hey chill started shooting AR-15
not nearly as intimidating as many
people would think loved it uh hit
subscribe like we very much enjoying gun
weak we're going to do the next
installment if you click ballistics
ballistics gel it's into gel yep we
spared no expense it's been sitting out
in the hot sun because you told me that
makes it more clear it does a little bit
of heat on the outside sharpens it up a
little bit and then the ones that I am
looking forward to most is uh two
installments of dispelling the most
common myths one will be the
installments collaterally
literally culturally collaterally is
what I was talking we just you know I
just applied for a credit card literally
historically politically right uh though
culturally those kinds of myths and then
obviously since we have an expert Mr
gunziger we'll go through some of the
technical myths with Firearms hopefully
this helps you with some of these rungs
on the ladder and we'll see you out in
the shooting range um but I probably
won't be there but they might be there
we'll see
and our thanks to the folks at the tdsa
range in Ferris Texas it was hot but it
was wonderful if you like this video
click like consider subscribing or
comment below and of course consider
tuning in to the live show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern right here
on this channel